hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play drunk
minecraft I'm here with Bob and Wade as
usual guys hi guys and ladies there are
ladies that watch this - our girls don't
watch you I have so many fangirls you
wouldn't believe I don't believe it okay
hello Molly it's not true
Molly doesn't watch this she only
watches it because I'm in it she doesn't
watch anything you do accept all of your
settlers of catan Oh actually she
refuses to watch those but she was in
some of them that's why she refuses to
watch them yeah they're so bad anyway
so since I won the last one I get
absolutely no benefit we are going to
revisit the build of our Slenderman
statue right behind the glorious statues
that we made over here hang on what de I
can't fly anymore
I can fly magical camera in the sky I
will help you okay I'm gay the power hi
hi take away he's just a car whatever I
don't use it anymore but let me keep as
you could see the wade was in his crown
on his statue we're gonna set up this
new statue of Slenderman right behind
these and we will have 20 minutes to
build the best Slenderman that we can
this is gonna be a more low-key episode
we've been drinking a while wait and I
have anyway so looking for bomb waiting
for Bob okay we record this in like
three or four at a time so there could
be a nice low-key episode talking about
you know current events I'm gonna pull
up some news while we try to make the
best Lenny man as long as these here we
need a heal thing by the by I forgot
that we could use the heal things do not
mix what doesn't mix Ricci cups and
jingling Oh like toothpaste and beer
yeah oh all right so anyway are you guys
ready do you have your are you ready to
mow no it's low-key nice and quiet
Rumble I I happen to be ready to rumble
are you okay let us begin in wait who
gonna I'll gonna start the clock I'm
gonna go start the clock because I
always wanted to how do you start the
clock I didn't there's a but I just
worked by a magic there yeah
zombie magic hahaha magic mark zombies
are magic they're virus based hey that
only depends on if they are virus based
ssam bees anyway I must start the clock
ready there he'll sign over here it's
good Biscay sky boskie scrub you ski
wait isn't going get it mate we going ah
we're going alright let's go talk has
started excuse how no yes start this oh
hell wide I don't really know if he has
feet go as wide as possible I guess it's
Washington awesome Jason mommy's on the
step he's got a wide stance you know we
should face him on the slender arrival
Slenderman
woo can he have tentacles shooting out
his back - sure I want you to be able to
do you remember the last time we tried
to build something with wool hey I know
we're gonna be fun we got a lot of time
own assless chaps but we're working
together on this one so wait statue that
has a slit shafts is right over there
yeah yeah so we can stare at it wow
stare at the glory of the ash cheesy-ass
catcher
oh one when you spray a white soft huh
he doesn't have a wider yearning this
far wide or one or four wide for three
yeah four boop be doop boop boop boop
boop boop
ah-ha-ha-ha-ha I screwed it up already
okay shaping these feet like this um oh
yeah kind of layered you know stair-step
like stick it stick it in there like
that yeah just kind of jam it in there
and what are you guys doing over there
wiggle it around a bit how are we why
what is this it's a foot what do you
think it is you're facing the opposite
way no it's it's facing towards the
statues okay he's watching us cuz he's
gonna get us yeah he does that
oh he's gonna get yeah that's what the
Slenderman does he get yeah
yeah does that look hideous as [ __ ] that
is cool yeah no that's great that
actually does Oh actually it looks
pretty good once it starts we don't have
any shears the wicket cheers oh they're
shears in the other one
oh how good see oh ah it's more
efficient grieving I'll let you die no I
just scream at random points just that I
shouldn't have white socks or so he
doesn't have socks uh he was over here
like his suit is part of his body or
something I don't know nobody's got
socks on this one well why how far up
does his groin go I don't know it's
gotta be pretty he's a lanky bastard so
long legs maybe yeah right there that's
probably good place for the groin start
to like Bridget Bridget out to the other
one oh oh wait what wait you don't feel
in the center that's a waste that's not
the center that is the center what else
oh I see I made his legs smaller than
his foot like oh okay I got ya he's got
cankles it kind of goes all into one
mark as you look at his leg oh yeah I
see he's got really stick thin legs
there but yeah wait no we'll go with
yours we'll go with yours Wade's
thickness is there can we whatever this
episode ends remember the type of leg
that they were trying to build
cooperatively for this guy hey our legs
man with cankles
it is it is is good ironic yeah okay I'm
gonna go get a shears just clean up what
we have screwy I don't know if we're
gonna go with Wade's or ours yet but
something's gonna happen I don't really
know Oh shoes are so ugly
shut up they're fine sorry he's got
fashion their fashion forward
that's not correct it's like how
hipsters roll up there um his jeans at
the shoe
yes kind of hipster Slenderman right now
listening Trender man this is gonna be
trend grooming note these legs aren't
even even what about his Gooch it's all
what why we go that it was asking what
something was it was gonna be his Gooch
yeah even Slenderman has a Gooch okay
Blender Gooch
what is this extra growth right here
haha hey don't ask questions she's very
embarrassed about it let's see all right
if that's the center it's got to come
out a bit right has got to come out from
the front and back
oh yeah that lines up a bit kind of get
rid of this other part of it yeah yeah I
got it I got it I got it
my original scheme has gone to pot so I
guess we're just going with ways one I
guess Wade I didn't win the last round I
guess whatever your scheme was giving
Slenderman cankle and what was wrong
with that everything
it's name is Slenderman sweet huh you
haven't even played us is worse there's
a job jobs Hey [ __ ] hey hey the jub jubs
are people too
my name is Steve oh okay here you wait
there Bob there you go oh there you go
ah cheers for like 10 minutes ah
we haven't even been going for 10
minutes we've been going for long I
didn't have a before we started either
oh that's true well then if you go by
logic we haven't had shoes for many
games why is there a giant hole in the
clock what there's a giant hole in the
clock hey can we get some a light gray
or dark gray wool so I can make like a
little belt doesn't even belt is anyone
keeping track of time I guess I I didn't
start this is the one time I didn't
start my timer on the side it would be
going somewhere between zero and ten
minutes okay good Ari I think like I
don't know maybe five minutes yeah
whatever that's in between the two
things I said that works yeah cuz I
collect it anyway let's talk about
current events so uh
there was a new pope hot why is his
crotch completely [ __ ]
hey we're Gus we're getting to it
lurking the truck we're gonna hey hey
it's just shut up it's just a first part
hang on
keep your [ __ ] together while we just
work on this Jesus ha ha ha ha sighs
that better he's he's a biker and he's
got a boss massive quantity making
Slenderman so much better wait how did
we do the other one then how did was the
other one better nipples that's all I
remember
all right whatever I turn off the rain
somebody rain turn off his body
slash wait whoa
shot by car out there we go it worked
I sent rain to Sun in the world yay
lame-o Lee bad word good job there Wade
remember we don't need to fill the
center because that's just a waste of
wool yeah I am zombie right yeah huh no
you how tall are we making them this is
too tall this is too tall his legs are
long enough ha ha ha ha
okay all right I'm just going with it
you know whatever you get you guys just
don't know artistic division I love a
love cam all over the place be serious
this time and it's gonna be really
really accurate is that what I said
oh no okay anyway so current events yeah
how about that good to distract from
what's going on here think about Bo
yeah the Pope yeah and there's a new
quote right that's he's yeah yeah
Argentina something right something like
that Pope Francis I don't know been
doing good Francis and luckily I'm not
Catholic or this would be really
embarrassing but I don't know a whole
lot about that ol yeah none hope thing
yep okay that's all for current events
and that was like a month ago what the
hell are you doing occurred by the time
is episode that's like middle school
current events that's not actual
appeared events I'm sure like North
Korea is balmy almost like in North
Korea I thought that might be a little
bit too depressing
hey given that I am Korean and for our
North Korean viewers yeah oh you know
Korean marker you can't you know I am
part of the best Korea he's that Korean
that is mixed with German whatever part
of Korea that is yeah well you know
right along the border of Korea and
Germany ah
hey I can't see anything this thing is
too black and it's night can you know
what day oh oh oh thank you oh I do that
100 Bieber NICUs well she never get
yourself to the back of the line
what's that from my guy oh I've been
watching I don't remember that one
cutting in line in from uh Italian guys
oh yeah oh yeah I remember
oh hey yeah that's what sounded like
Marc are you feeling in the middle of
Jesus just fill in the middle no I'm not
filling in the middle I'm filling in the
outside whoever did that who's not me
I'm not filling in the middle it's
basically in the back where do i where
is his tie where's this neck hahahaha
almost out of wool every time I step
back and I look at it it's
all the alcohol in ha ha ha look at that
my idea we're gonna make this time
really really slow hey I got is there an
actual middle to this or is it not even
ah there's two in the middle okay that's
good that's good we could just make it
at or maybe we need to make white around
it to make the tie and I got this around
a she's gonna have a collar to find his
neck area and I'll start filling it I
got it right here this is gonna be the
neck area how far out is that gonna go a
little cut right here ah I should not
fill those in huh uh uh yeah that's good
all right I'll keep filling in the
bottom here I'll do my technique of
going from the bottom because that works
much better
mmm just gonna be the same color as his
head because we're not using like a
grayish color um yeah no he's all white
and black that's how it works her baby
there's no okay well his shirt in his
face or just gonna be like the same
being yeah sure okay and sunder the
arrival his his face was like this grace
not green it was really weird
oh that's weird yeah I mean I know no I
guess I'm like well let me make the tie
would you do what did you do hang on
you're all laughing I'm not looking now
look at this huge - what the hell this
isn't even pixel art this is just wrong
I don't know folks I was like oh yeah
yeah oh no it's all right it's all right
it's all right
like we are making him tentacles yeah
tentacles on the back and stuff like
that fleshing out the back part yeah
okay I guess that's important if people
are gonna actually see that tentacles
coming off of this bag
ah just do the technique that I'm doing
it's very very very efficient I know
I've been doing that yeah alright more
current events um wait how's your
channel doing they're pretty good a lot
of people that have been watching here
have been coming over huh I get more
videos up as mark knows I just got a
hard drive I need to install so I can
actually hold a lot more stuff on there
cuz I had to delete a whole bunch of
stuff every time I've recorded I've had
to delete things very well that's what
you get for getting a 500 gig hard drive
for your first start that's what I get
for being broke when I bought well
that's cuz you were trying to make a
Diablo 3 machine so yeah look how that
turned out for you pretty good it runs
really well
oh yeah it does because some genius
helped you with her right right um right
right thanks mom
your mom ha ha ha now mark did help me
build like up here was really awesome
and that's the trick I am your mom with
emails and asking to help you build and
build your computer please god no
well send me your computer in the mail
and I'll return a shoebox you'll
certainly see it if someone actually
sent me a computer it'd be like I
wouldn't even know what to do with it
okay so one sends you a computer can I
have it cuz I bet you for that as all of
its been allocated to Hort nor mine
they're my horse nothing none one horse
what horseradish horseradish yeah I was
thinking back to a live stream or I'm
very unfortunate emails were sent to you
ha ha ha ha ha ha oh yeah those I
remember now uh that was a fun why are
these tentacles like just one block
looking structures hey I didn't start
[ __ ]
I do not start this I'm just trying to
mimic what was going on oh I like that
you can see all the way good because I
think someone was gonna build his head I
thought I was doing the tentacles oh man
Oh at the back I can see the high from
behind him you know if you're in that
the thing is if we added nipples it
would look less ridiculous than it does
now because at least they would be
anatomically correct
this body is not an atomic right
therefore nipples could not you to be
shut up well yes in a way this is like
the scariest Slenderman ever if this was
behind me I would be much more worried
at least you know he couldn't keep up
with you because of his haha him stumble
well he doesn't actually walk so it just
be kind of a you know sliding action
towards you get someone make a mod where
this is the Slenderman in a game I would
play it so much cuz I mean be honest if
this came at you in the middle of the
woods would you not [ __ ] your pants and
be totally afraid probably yeah yeah see
yeah we're doing good we're doing good
alright his backs almost done yay
he doesn't have a horrible now it
doesn't it yeah see stand corrected
the heads gonna be the only thing that
looks good on this cuz I had creative
control over it to be fair you made the
torso the height that it is shut up oh
you were the one who started shut up you
guys don't know my oh no I give up
you guys you do whatever you want I
don't care anymore
I always do guys are you making a dick
come out of his now no but I should know
no I should do let me go get the pink
wool here mark mark where what we're on
the top of the head yeah pink wool yeah
take you out I need a lot more than that
I need so much pink wool oh no that's
his head it looks like he's got a really
long head and the rest of his his mouth
not his time ah oh he's like one of the
amnesia monsters could we turn him into
an amnesia monster Slenderman a grunts
agar-agar on Slenderman yeah
Guddu dad please wanted no ha
haha it works just time what is that
that's not fixed what is that what is
that that's so wait hang on it needs no
it's not fixed hang on I'll fix it you
just wait yeah there we go
and put some down here they would've
realized that we gave him tentacles you
a tongue looking his tongue tiles like a
tongue hahahaha and he's got no heart
oh [ __ ] I forgot the arms no um I'll
just carve arms into the torso hahaha
yeah you know he's got keeping him close
at his side's and he's really hippy you
know no he's got hip she's you know he's
got curves you know what I mean yeah
don't don't question my words don't do
it my words man go guys we need to keep
a tighter leash on me
hahaha I'm just making it worse well
it's not like we're making it better
come stand on top of my Homer Simpson
hair that you built me and look at this
monstrosity oh my god hahaha what
happened we set out to do something good
look at this face I think is that I
think face it's a tie no not it is like
a merging of some and I if if I had
created a control on the ankles this
would have gone so much better because
you destroyed my vision I had a plan and
it just I want to [ __ ] it was no it does
not look okay because it looks like he's
got clogs on black clogs
sizes torso hahahaha and the budget and
you're worried about the kind of shoes
yes I am of course because in the first
world problem the right
does it make sense it makes sense cuz
he's Slenderman okay uh I guess we're
done
you've got no arms are like oh wait no
we cannot wait we can fix this we needs
arms that's what the one thing we need
to add before we're done here
he needs some sort of arms oh I have an
idea it's ours gonna be really shortened
stubbly like his legs Oh yep yeah yep
yep yep oh my god what is this hahaha
hahaha that's good right yeah like that
oh just copy that go right through the
tentacle it don't matter
yeah like that did that have that one
scratch in his armpit like a monkey can
I do that let me do that this has to go
back down to his armpit yeah and I got
this back off his arm back off I got
this you don't understand
his arm looks like just another one of
his tentacles you don't know my words
for my message whatever I'm doing
uh-uh oh man this is so bad like I knew
it wasn't gonna look good but yeah what
we're not artists what are you talking
about you talking about this is an
insult to what art is everywhere yaaaaah
where's his armpit there it is way up
there why'd you turn it day thank you
Bob whoa I was yeah it's clear and um
what have you done to this head is
pointing he's pointing he's model finger
look it's crappy finger Oh No happy
about the way
hahaha have you seen his other arm this
is so much worse than Oh statue with me
with a penis in my mouth looking at the
worst thing we've ever wait did you guys
still have pink wool yeah I do need some
help
yet what do we need here I'll drop it
Slendy nipples oh you want to actually
add nipples for Slenderman I mean it
can't possibly any worse hahaha oh ye of
little faith
does not know the potential of drunk
friends together
wait there's yellow there's yellow wool
in here what can we get that we should
go out and boobs if we're gonna give
them hand huh oh god this like yeah I
guess the [ __ ] saw what is that
wearing tassels haha cadence Ken Ken the
nipples no that would not work okay I
have an idea
what no what's it well just just just
hang on all right
I'm following you wait that's not enough
pink on the other one it's very lopsided
now that's now that would be too much
pink the other one needs more pink it is
are they shooting lasers yeah ah ah
that's awesome that's so hardcore this
one little war pig yeah we need one here
I will yellow do I know but sure now
yellow doesn't it has to look right I
mean at least if we're gonna do
something we might as well do it like
correctly are you play some I'll shave
them okay got it
hurry dick God there we go are they
falling well I don't know what Bob's
last lasers doing I think it there you
only specific target what target yeah
you try to aim it at my ass I don't
think it's good
work Bob there's not enough it's not
enough angle there doesn't say how do
they go from being perfectly straight to
angling haha yeah these are lasers you
know that they go straight right what's
our time looking X we've been going for
at least we're done basically we're
pretty much done with this uh wait Bob I
think we just gotta let this one lie no
cuz right now it just looks like he's
shooting blood out of his nipple oh my
god that's really bad oh I don't rip oh
no oh no it's getting suddenly got worse
we said it couldn't get worse worse oh
my god who wants to take responsibility
for this one yeah I think the winner is
whoever gets blamed for this all right
we're done so uh zombie you want to
intervene here cuz things went wrong a
long time ago I'm gonna fight all three
of us for this Oh everyone loses good
good oh my god I don't even know what
expression is this what is it why is he
pointing
why is he scratching his armpit why
version of I'm a fire and malaysia's ha
ha ha ha
oh god then we need blue wool coming out
his mouth that might work Oh
oh man ok so if everyone loses that's
that I don't know what is that I don't
know it just looks weird
yeah no it's dumb yeah god you're such a
good piece of [ __ ] no it's better it
looks like a duck no it's a chicken
looks like a chicken
connect this red stuff connect the red
stuff it's it's red giblet on the
chicken connect it someone with red
there we go it's a chicken
hahahahahaha actually works now zombie
who won who won that is so much better
though okay Dockyard okay we're all
losers okay so um I don't know what to
make of this episode way this is more oh
okay oh let mean I win no I'm pretty
sure you're just losing Oh who's adding
who's adding a penis who's invisible
adding a penis oh really
oh oh I thought you were oh you were
under it for me I win I don't think so
chickens from the sky yeah alright
that's God look this is beautiful this
is a beautiful way to end end it so I
guess we'll just handle it here so thank
you all so much for watching um we're
all losers in life just remember that
even if you think you're losing remember
that some people are losing more like
Wade
so yeah Wade has a YouTube channel what
plays lots of Settlers of Catan um
really really great stuff never never
gonna get old
hahaha bob has an awesome twitter
account you should follow him everything
is in the description so um don't ever
do what we do
drinking is bad I'm drinking playing
Minecraft is evil it's like a pancake oh
god don't question it wait don't
question so thank you everybody again
click for more drunk my cuffed and as
always we will see you in the next video
ow
No
Oh
though